aujourd'hui jeudi 23 avril 2015 bonsoir
bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal de la
rédaction de tv fil 26 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actualité locale et
il sera notamment question de ce nouveau
multiplexe en préparation à maurepas les
responsables des salles alentour ont
notamment dû signer ses talents cour
s'inquiète une pétition contre cette
implantation circule actuellement pas de
festival rock sur versailles cette année
l'association en charge de
l'organisation évoque des chutes de
subventions une volonté de la
municipalité est de mettre fin à ce
rendez vous et puis une dizaine de jours
après elle son élection au poste de
maire de coignières jean-pierre sevestre
sera en plateau pour nous parler de ses
projets et bien sûr de son prédécesseur
henri paillet la chambre des métiers et
de l'artisanat à versailles réagi aux
dernières annonces de bercy et se
satisfait d'ouvrir le choix d'ouvrir aux
entreprises
le nouveau mécanisme de déduction
fiscale aux entreprises artisanales
mécanisme qui permet jusqu'au 14 avril à
2016 de réduire l'impôt en déduisant
l'acquisition la fabrication de certains
biens et d'équipements et puis du côté
du conseil départemental des yvelines
cette fois-ci vous en avez vu les images
on réagit également mais aux dernières
annonces du gouvernement qui pour son
projet de grand paris prévoit la
construction de plusieurs milliers de
logements et 10 milles sur versailles et
saint cyr l'école ou encore 4650 à
saint-germain-en-laye les élus évoquent
un déni de démocratie ils s'opposent à
ces décisions jugées arbitraires de
l'état une polémique à présent du côté
de versailles où le festival du potager
à du rock qui existait depuis maintenant
huit ans organisé par l'association in
versailles devrait disparaître il n'aura
pas lui en tout cas cette année en
désaccord entre l'association mais aussi
la mairie sur le concert de clôture
serait à l'origine de l'abandon de ce
projet les explications de catherine il
attend les férus d'europe vont être
déçus le festival du potager du rock pop
planté depuis huit ans à versailles
n'aura pas lieu cette année une décision
de l'association universal y en faut
selon eux tout d'abord une subvention
trop faible de l'amérique quelques
années on avait encore de 1000 euros et
depuis l'année dernière seulement
ensemble mais surtout selon
l'association le refus de la ville
d'autoriser là tenue d'un concert de
clôture en plein air hélas pas justement
pas qu'une question de budget puisqu'ils
ont aussi refusé l'organisation d'un
nouveau plein air de créatures qui était
un peu justement le le
les mêmes événements culminant de ce
festival
ils ont refusé qu'on refasse un plein
air en nous proposant comme seule
alternative d'aller faire ce concert de
clôture dans des maisons de quartiers
qui sont des salles polyvalentes un peu
excentré dans la ville beaucoup moins
central qui seront aussi pas équipés
pour pour pas adapté pour recevoir
les événements des concerts
de musiques actuelles dans des bonnes
conditions des conditions
professionnelles comme on essaye de le
proposer en mairie l'adjointe à la
culture se déclare surprise de la
décision de l'association d'arrêter le
festival décision qu'elle dit avoir
appris par un communiqué et elle revient
sur ce choix de ne pas autoriser ce
concert de clôture en plein air en
réalité ce qui s'est passé c'est que
pour des raisons techniques matériels et
autres
on n'avait plus autorisé l'année
dernière et que cette année c'est vrai
que c'est très compliqué ça a été
beaucoup de complications en fait
technique matériel de sécurité etc
et du coup cette année on ne peut pas le
faire mais du coup on avait proposé
beaucoup de choses pour 20 pouvoir les
aider est ce que c'est important et
notamment des concerts en maison de
quartier et de défendre la politique
culturelle de la ville notamment en
matière de musiques actuelles
je veux vraiment insister sur le fait
qu'on ne laissera jamais tomber le rock
est jamais tomber les musiques actuelles
donc a pas de souci là-dessus
faute d'avoir trouvé un accord
satisfaisant l'association a donc dû
jeter l'épongé
il n'y aura plus le potager de rock à
versailles avant de cesser leur activité
la trentaine de bénévoles convie les
amateurs à un dernier concert le 13 mai
à la royale factory avec notamment
johnny montreuil et la colère des
responsables du ciné c est l encours à
présent le cinéma vient d'apprendre
qu'un multiplexe devrait être construit
sur la commune de maurepas à moins de
quatre kilomètres de ses locaux le
projet a été validé par la commission
nationale d'aménagement commercial
un dossier qui prévoit la création de
huit salles de 1700 fauteuil dans le
village des loisirs de la zone paris
ouest à l'horizon 2016 on écoute lucmau
quand le responsable du ciné cette année
en cours pour nous c'est un projet qui
est purement opportuniste et dire qu'ils
visent à éventuellement sauver le
village des loisirs de maurepas qui est
installé depuis des années qu'ils
fonctionnent pas bien tout le monde le
sait mais il n'y a pas de justification
demande de salle et cetera puisque l'on
a été rénové et agrandi
on fonctionne très bien il y aura un
projet à plaisir prochainement qui vit
d'ailleurs avait été acceptée il faut
savoir que si ce projet sûrement pas est
acceptée c'est parce que le projet de
plaisir et en somme est aujourd'hui mais
on sait que la volonté de madame le
maire de plaisir c'est faire un
multiplexe de me sall à plaisir donc
résultat des courses
à terme on aura probablement l'outil
plaque savoure pas qui sera mal placé
qui est avec centre f et cetera et
cetera
un multiplexe à plaisir et un projet qui
étaient déposés sur coignières si la
semaine dernière on a appris ça donc
allons-y pourquoi pourquoi pas continuer
et puis à versailles comme vous le savez
vélizy parly 2 c'est donc ça fait
beaucoup
je trouve et ça fait beaucoup de trop
pour tenter de faire annuler ce projet
une pétition vient d'être lancée en
ligne le permis de construire n'a pas
encore été délivré par la mairie de
maurepas est l'invité de cette édition
du 23 avril jean-pierre sevestre bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le nouveau maire de
coignières élu par les autres membres de
cette assemblée locale le 11 avril pour
pallier à la démission d'henri pailleux
une paix en poste depuis 1986 vous étiez
jusqu'à présent adjoint chargé des
affaires économiques
à quel moment votre candidature s'est
imposé la candidature s'est imposé au
moment de la démission effectivement
d'henri pailleux lors de ses voeux le 30
janvier dernier à ces faux site où vous
vous êtes dit ah ça y est c'est mon père
je me suis dit peut-être c'est mon heure
peut-être oui peut-être peut-être parce
que j'avais et j'ai eu immédiatement
lors d'eire de cette cérémonie des voeux
et de du cocktail qui suivait j'ai eu
l'appui de nombreux membres de mon
équipe de l'équipe de mon équipe
maintenant et donc j'ai considéré qu'il
était possible effectivement que je
succède à henri pailleuse qu'il n'est
pas une tâche très aisée
je le pont je conseille à bloc on savait
bien sûr vous n'avez pas de plan de
carrière en politique vous avez comme
don fait à peu près 14 ans il ya 14 ans
il a commencé
j'ai intégré l'équipe d'henri pas lieu
parce que je considère que depuis depuis
1986 et bien avant d'ailleurs pour pour
henry au service de la collectivité
puisqu'il est au service de coignières
depuis 1977 au titre d'association soit
au titre de la municipalité et de
l'équipe municipale et j'ai intégré en
2001 effectivement dès la fin de mon
activité professionnelle
l'équipe municipale dans l'équipe de
nori pailleux coignières démocratie
ancien cadre bancaire pour un ancien
cadre bancaire professionnelle voilà et
cette arrivée dans la politique
aujourd'hui vous avez pris goût vous non
c'est pas l'homme politique ce n'est pas
la politique pour moi
pour moi c'est c'est la rencontre avec
les connais rien c'est la rencontre avec
les habitants avec nos voisins avec la
population et m'intégrer et servir
l'ensemble de la population pour le
bien-être pour le bien vivre de la
collectivité alors que ce soit
effectivement au niveau de l'urbanisme
que ce soit au niveau des affaires
économiques de l'emploi puisque j'étais
adjoint à l'emploi également que ce soit
au niveau également peut-être de la
petite enfance également parce que j'ai
participé avec dominique atteint qui
maintenant prendre ma première adjointe
de nombreuses années à l'évolution de de
la petite enfance mais également la
sécurité les transports etc
je précise le z sans étiquette et je
joue en sélection c'est cette liste
était plutôt de sensibilité droite son
centre au droit que pense henri pas lieu
de vous justement on va l'écouter il
était l'invité du café politique sur
téléphiles récemment vous aller
surveiller ce que va faire votre prêt
c'est votre successeur pardon je vais
terminer ces municipales non je reste au
conseil municipal le message est assez
logique et c'est assez normal mais je ne
reste pas là je dirais pour surveiller
de gens perçoivent est donc
bien évidemment j'aurais l'oeil sur ce
qu'il doit faire je ne pense pas qu'il
sorte je dirais du cadre telles que je
les tracés depuis 30 ans enfin croit
souvent déclamés et donc je serai là je
dirais pour garantir ou essayer de
garantir la continuité mais je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude j'en percevais c'est un
garçon sérieux c'est un bosseur qui est
très présent sur le terrain également
et je pense qu'il a toutes les qualités
pour gérer la vie de qualité sérieux
bosseur il a tout de même mehdi voilà
j'espère qu'il ne va pas sortir du cadre
qui est bien tracée depuis 30 ans yves
tout à fait là mais je suis dans la
continuité dans la continuité de
l'action d'henri pas eu depuis depuis de
nombreuses années et si j'étais dans son
équipe effectivement bien sûr bien sûr
nous nous sommes engagés en 2014 sur un
programme et je vais continuer bien sûr
ce programme puisque nous sommes engagés
vis-à-vis des coignard rien et notamment
la rénovation du gymnase qui doit
intervenir rapidement
également le réaménagement du centre
village et notamment pour ce qui
concerne le parking notamment nous avons
un parkings en étage qui est unity
inutilisés pour des raisons de sécurité
il nous faut absolument pouvoir évoluer
cette affaire et puis l'extension de
l'extension du gymnase gelé précisé mais
également le remplacement du mobilier
urbain pour permettre aussi d'avoir un
environnement de qualité
et puis l'aménagement également des
circulations et des trottoirs des voix
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
parce que nous avons comme partout une
population qui doit bouger bien sûr et
qui débouchait doit bouger en sécurité
également équidés sécurité bien nous
avons déjà un programme de
vidéoprotection qui a été mis en place
et dans les années à venir je pense que
nous pourrions faire évoluer également
ce ce système de vidéoprotection et
c'est une ville qui se porte plutôt bien
la ville de coignières c'est la deuxième
commune la plus riche des yvelines
derrière vélizy beaucoup d'entreprises
qui sont présentes beaucoup de chantiers
de rénovation et qui ont déjà été menées
je pensais l'église la mairie aussi a
connu toute son extension
récemment c'est une ville facile à gérer
vous arrivez dans les meilleurs des
conditions en tout cas alors j'arrive
j'arrive henry pailleux m'a laissé une
situation qui effectivement est une très
bonne situation une très bonne situation
financière
maintenant j'arrive dans les meilleures
conditions oui on me laisse une
situation effectivement et j'en remercie
henry et je veux encore apporter un
appui extraordinaire au travail de
d'henri au cours de toutes ces années je
veux encore le faire remarquer mais
j'arrive dans des conditions tout de
même qu'ils sont un peu particulière
puisque nous avons d'un côté la baisse
des dotations budgétaires de l'état et
qui vont se poursuivre jusqu'en 2010 est
maintenant espérons l'échéance de 2017
est ensuite eh bien nous avons cette
transition intercommunale qui doit
intervenir
peut-être en fin d'année ou un peu plus
tard avec la communauté d'agglomération
et cinq ans devrait réintégrer saint
quentin en yvelines qui doit d'ailleurs
réintégrés s'ils voient le 1er janvier
2016 soit éventuellement on évoque un
report mais rien n'est encore officiel
et ce ne serait qu'un délai de quelques
mois supplémentaires
alors on va y venir justement à ce
retour dans l'agglomération de la de
coignières dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines juste auparavant peu
plus tôt dans le journal il était
question de ce multiplex qui est
pourrait qui devrait voir le jour là
aussi du côté de maurepas probablement
aussi sur coignières un dossier aura été
déposés un cinéma
sur coignières c'est envisageable alors
je viens de prendre connaissance
effectivement dans votre dans votre
début de journal du problème qui se pose
dorénavant avec l'obtention par maurepas
diala cn assez de l'autorisation de
construire multiplex de huit salles je
pense à ça c'était de cette opération
qui était en suspens depuis un moment
effectivement il y à une opération qui a
été déposée il ya quelques jours à la
préfecture pour un multiplexe à
coignières je pense que ce soir nous
pouvons réfléchir effectivement au
nombre de salles qui sont en train de se
multiplier rire ça ne me semble pas
forcément pertinent 1 cm à coignières
pour la vie en plus pour l'instant si on
a effectivement s'il y en a un au
village de loisirs amour pas je ne vois
pas comment et si s'il se réalise parce
que ça n'est pas encore fait mais je ne
vois pas comment nous pourrions
effectivement mettre de nouveau
multiplexe boulevard des arpents à
coignières aurait déjà infecté veut
rassurer peut-être le signer cet appel
en cours encore au grenier à sel à la
trappe peut être fatigué ce sera à voir
au cours d un des prochains mois les
réactions sur le vif
l'enjeu c'est bien évidemment l'arrivée
de coignières dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines où on va il
parlait juste après on va en parler
juste après ce micro-trottoir comment
voyez-vous votre commune la ville de
coignières dans une dizaine d'années
c'est la question que nous sommes allés
poser à vos administrés je pense que
elle sera beaucoup plus développé dans
le sens où il y aura plus le parking
juste là et avec plus habitant je pense
et une population un peu plus jeunes une
ville où tout le monde puissent
coexister une ville
avec des services qui continueront
d'exister j'espère ville avec des jeunes
pas de grands changements ne considère
pourquoi lire plutôt comme un petit
village
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
constructions donc du coup bah on garde
toujours le même aspect urbain ya
peut-être d'autres magasins qui vont se
mettre à côté on a déjà une grosse zone
commerciale mais c'était peut-être
s'agrandir encore façon ça fait plus de
dix ans que je la sens c'est toujours la
même chose
donc non je vote toujours pareil dans
dix ans coignard toujours pareil dans
dix ans votre poignet je ne suis pas
devin je ne suis pas de projet justement
comment vous l'imaginez l évolution de
la ville sur les les années qui restent
deux mandats et les projets que vous
allez initier les projets que je vais
initiés actuellement n'importe pas dans
une dans une première dans une première
étape si vous voulez une vue la
continuité de notre programme jusqu'en
2020 nous n'avons pas de perspective de
modification de la ville mais je tiens à
préciser que et je lui ai entendu là
dans le micro trottoir
je tiens à conserver à à coignières la
notion de petites villes à taille
humaine
je ne souhaite pas transformer
coignières comme une ville seulement
urbaine si vous voulez nous sommes tout
de même une ville avec une 30 partie de
zones vertes et l'esprit village
l'esprit village l'esprit de vivre
ensemble esprit de bien-être et l'esprit
de service également de proximité nous
avons des services de proximité qui sont
de qualité et je tiens à conserver ses
services de de qualité des attaquants et
dans l'agglomération justement de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça peut
remettre en cause tous à quel message de
remettre en cause le non pourquoi
remettre en cause nos services est
rassuré parce que son replay yeux qui
est de démissionner donc à qui vous avez
succédé à henri pailleuse c'est l'une
des raisons de sa démission c'est cette
arrivée de la ville de coignières dont
l'agglomération de 50 ans l'une des
raisons de sa démission c'est
l'intégration effectivement de
coignières
dans la casse qui maintenant que nos
services de proximité soit transformé
avec notre arrivée dans la casse qui je
ne le souhaite pas et je ne veux pas et
c'est c'est dans mon souhait si vous
voulez dans la continuité aussi c'est de
conserver ses services de conserver ses
services de qualité de proximité
qu'appelle-t-on services de proximité
alors si nous appelons effectivement
peut-être refaire une carte d'identité
ou des choses comme ça mais les services
de proximité ce sont les crèches ce sont
ces ces choses là c'est le théâtre c'est
le centre de loisirs ce sont les écoles
de sport et toutes ces choses qui ont
été créés par henri pailleux il faut
continuer il faut le conserver
donc vous êtes méfiant avec cette
arrivée dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin
quel état d'esprit vous arrivez à 50 ans
nue mais j'arrive dans un état d'esprit
nous sommes nous sommes devant la loi
nous sommes devant la loi une obligation
de fait ça y est je vais être hacker de
m'intégrer dans sept dans cette
communauté d'agglomération dans
l'intérêt de tous et notamment bien sûr
en préservant les intérêts des connais
rien je sais je sais bien sûr que la
situation de coignières la situation
avec les nombreux commerces situation
financière de coignières intéresse bien
sûr toutes les communes environnantes
mais je pense qu'ils ne tiendraient j'ai
à coeur de d'avoir une transition et de
maintenir l'action municipale à
l'échelon intercommunal coignard a plus
à perdre ou à gagner avec cette arrivée
dans saint quentin en yvelines bien
j'espère qu'on ne va pas y perdre mais
qu'on va y gagner
merci jean réal 16 c'est à souhait c'est
un souhait merci j'apercevais ce nouveau
maire donc les deux coignières d'avoir
réagi à ces différents sujets avec nous
ce soir
la suite du journal avec ce jeudi matin
la section de montigny le bretonneux de
l'union nationale des combattants et la
fédération des yvelines qui ont organisé
une cérémonie un peu particulière une
cérémonie sous les couleurs de la france
pour la remise officielle d'un nouveau
drapeau élus locaux membres de l'ump se
sont rassemblées devant le monument aux
morts de montigny le bretonneux donc on
écoute jean-claude bouvier au micro à 2
mathilde eu qu'à berne de patrick
jacques de dixmude
alors aujourd'hui il faisant une remise
de drapeau
c'est une cérémonie protocolaire et donc
le département
des yvelines est représenté avec tous
les penseurs drapeaux et les présidents
des îles
c'est une cérémonie protocolaire c'est
un peu particulier remise de drapeau
donc c'est quand même l'emblème de la
france et il faut respecter tout ça et
c'est pourquoi il ya tous ces drapeaux
qui sont là présents aujourd'hui un
nouveau drapeau
parce qu'il y en a qui est complètement
usés et puis nous avons un nouveau jeune
porte-drapeau qui est acquis on veut
qu'il ait un drapeau à porter pour leur
courage et environnement à présent tous
les deux mois la maison de quartier de
d'orly parc de la verrière organise une
randonnée pour découvrir la faune la
flore de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
biodiversité de l'étang des routières de
guyancourt et c'est à l'honneur ce mois
ci une dizaine d'explorateurs parti hier
à la découverte de la richesse de ce
site un reportage de michael et demi
d'euros et d'élodie moines les étangs
des rousses hier à guyancourt un trésor
caché une centaine de mètres de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est dans ce décor sauvage que la
maison de quartier orly-parc de la
verrière a organisé une randonnée verte
réservé aux habitants de la commune
au programme découverte de la faune et
de la flore de l'étang 1 pour ça qu'il
avait pas bien vu vous avez le héron que
juste en face et vous avez un canard
colvert qui arrive qui arrive sur l'os
et barel pendant près de deux heures les
randonneurs ont pu apercevoir un héron
des canetons encore des gaules ou sur le
site à l'aide d'une épuisette ces
apprentis explorateurs ont pu également
observer la vie sous-marine de l'étang
la roya demoiselle ici là et là henan
tout petit vous la voyez on voit bien
que derrière trois petits plis me
classer ya de la biodiversité
voilà ce qui est intéressant c'est
vraiment trop gentil que ma gueule
activités humaines on arrive quand même
à maintenir certains une certaine
richesse à protéger cet après midi
découverte est une expérience
surprenante et pédagogique pour les
randonneurs je m'attendais pas à trouver
des
et des oiseaux autant de enfin de
variétés au niveau animalière à 50 et en
fait j'ai appris à reconnaître les
oiseaux a les armes certaines choses que
nous montrer qu'on connaît pas forcément
tout seul le prochain rendez vous est
programmé en juin les randonneurs very
roi visiteront les étangs de
saint-hubert opéré en yvelines cette
fois ci la guide leur fera découvrir le
chant des oiseaux
un nouvel atelier original proposé
pendant ses vacances par la maison des
parents de trappes un atelier animé sur
cinq jours par l'association pour la
promotion de la citoyenneté des enfants
et des jeunes qui se conclura vendredi
par une reconstitution de procès dans la
salle du conseil municipal
sephora namani et elodie mois
parents enfants réunis pour un atelier
de vacances scolaires mais ici pas
question d'art plastique ou de jeu c'est
à une reconstitution de procès qu'ils
sont conviés invité par la piège à
réfléchir sur différentes affaires
thématiques auxquelles ils pourraient
être confrontés à kate violence scolaire
ou encore longue on a essayé aussi
d'assister sur des affaires qu'on peut
retrouver au sein des établissements
scolaires ou les collégiens sont assez
indifférent mais ni peuvent se retrouver
devant la justice par rapport à des
faits qui pour eux ne sont pas g c'est
vraiment une prise de conscience de la
vie quotidienne dans son quotidien à
l'école et en dehors de l'école
ce qu'on fait là mash up c'est c'est
bien qu'ils proposent des stages comme
ça aux enfants et avec les arts on sait
très bien
moi je trouve que c'est assez 120 parce
que ça change des stages qui a
d'habitude par exemple parfois pendant
les vacances ont fait que du sport et
sortir et là ça change on fait d'autres
choses et on apprend des nouvelles
choses pendant toute cette semaine le
groupe d'une trentaine de participants
va devoir choisir la sphère qu'il
reconstitueront ensemble ce vendredi un
procès auquel les parents sont conviés à
prendre pleinement part en tant que
parent en nylon ou part de
responsabilité
et c'est aussi pour les mobiliser et
pouvoir aussi transmettre l'information
à d'autres familles à d'autres parents
et d'être informés puisque la justice
souvent on est assez éloignée et il faut
la rendre plus simples à la portée de
tout le monde
l'atelier se dérouleront pendant toute
cette semaine la reconstitution de
procès très solennelle se déroulera donc
ce vendredi en salle du conseil
municipal de trappes la justice et la
citoyenneté une thématique abordée tout
au long de l'année dans la commune soit
par le biais d'ateliers comme celui ci
soit par des jeux une autre animation
sera proposée en mai et en juin au
collège le village
le journal revient demain aux mêmes
horaires avec à catherine zola tôt pour
l'information du jour et l'essentiel de
la semaine comme chaque vendredi bonne
soirée sur tv fils tout de suite file
echo hebdomadaire économique préparé
présenté par florine parfait